so the first one
um which a lot of guys will try to
defend
or even try to avoid and i'm going to
see if i can pull up this article here
because it was mentioned
as i was doing some research for my book
this is all pretty much
straight off the chapter out of my book
i'm just going to distill it for the
purpose of this video
here we go there's an article here
called the case for being a cuck believe
it or not
and oh look it's got a picture of ivanka
trump looking at justin trudeau let me
share the screen so i can just put it up
here for you guys briefly
they actually write articles about this
the case for being a cuck
and um you can just google this just uh
search it on
news it's available on uh looks like gq
magazine online
so um this is like pushed out in the
mainstream media
it's it's it's pretty it's pretty much
accepted
common uh it's even celebrated in some
cases
uh but it does exist and when you get
involved with a single mommy you have to
understand that you're signing up for
your own cuckoldry you might ask what is
a cuck what does cuckoldry mean rich
you know i'll dig up your definition
give you the dictionary version
they have a bird called the uh called
the kaku they
even have tv shows uh based off it as
well
dictionary meaning cuckold is a
is an insulting term for a husband whose
spouse
had has had a sexual affair cuck holder
can mean one of two things
the act of making a man a cuck by having
an affair or the state of being a
cuckold
uh if you dig further into the webster
definitions you can also see that
it's it's inclusive of raising another
man's child
sometimes it's known sometimes as
unknown one of the stats that i
pulled up doing some of the research
when i was putting the book together
was the rate at which
married men who believe that the
children that they are
raising are in fact their own are cucked
uh is somewhere between 10 and 30
percent
it's nearly impossible to establish
what the accurate numbers are because
the
active cuckoldry um in a marriage or in
a relationship
relies on deception so
nobody's going to volunteer oh by the
way this is not your kid i
had this with kevin from sales or steve
from accounting
she just goes about it and you know like
she understands paternity right
paternity is insured
because she burst the child the father
does not
have uh the option to ensure paternity
unless he takes a paternity test to
ensure that the offspring is his
but believe it or not even in a married
scenario even in a couple
the instances of cuckoldry are somewhere
between 10 and 30 percent
and all that data will be in another
chapter in my book i'm not going to
spend any time on it in this broadcast
but again society today celebrates what
this
is and in my view it's nothing to
celebrate
looking at articles titled the case for
being cuck
in my view is disgusting you don't have
the opportunity to pass on your last
name uh there's no
genetic legacy to pass down and these
two points have historically been the
biggest
selling points to men for fatherhood
this is why they would normally do it
right
so when you get involved with a single
mommy especially with small kids
you are in fact signing up for your own
cuckoldry you're walking into it
knowingly what you're doing
to add insult to injury women
overwhelmingly
have primary parenting of children the
vast majority of time and men don't
so if you're a divorce father and this
is going to come into play for a lot of
guys
you know 35 plus or so if you're a
divorced father you might actually end
up in a scenario
where you spend more parenting time some
other man's children than your own
so just let that settle in so that's the
first risk risk number one
you